magali stobart psychologue clinicienne
et psychothérapeute la galice aux
barthes bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous vous trouvez à
lisbonne comment est ce que la
population réagit à cette nouvelle
restriction cette nouvelle mise sous
cloche évident que personne n'est
satisfait par ce nouveau confinement
parce que on a toujours cru que le
premier confinement était suffisant pour
récupérer les questions sanitaires
or elles ont reprises et le gouvernement
a décidé de refaire un resserrement
cependant c'est un resserrement qui est
un peu différent de deux bars dans la
mesure où il ya quand même un peu plus
d'ouverture ce qui va permettre dans les
prochains jours d'évaluer si les les
restrictions sont suffisantes si on voit
que le les morts continue qui à chaque
fois plus de cas il est prévu de refaire
un autre resserrement dans quinze jours
alors le portugal lors de la première
vague a été relativement épargné par
rapport aux autres pays européens
est-ce que là bas aussi la nouvelle
variante du virus a été détecté
seulement un cas qui a été détectée donc
on est vraiment tout début j'ai entendu
hier donc qu'on va avoir des
restrictions avec les étrangers jusqu'à
présent on pouvait se faire les voyages
à l'étranger sans examen et maintenant
ils ont commencé à mettre des
restrictions comme faire un test avant
de partir ou recevoir un étranger allez
maintenant avec des restrictions voilà
c'est les nouvelles par rapport à mon
avis c'est une restriction liée aux à ce
nouveau virus
alors on sait que mercredi le pays a
enregistré un nouveau record de
contamination 156 morts également le
portugal qui compte dix millions
d'habitants
est-ce que sur place voilà on a
conscience du danger le port du masque
est il aujourd'hui obligatoire partout
oui il est déjà obligatoire depuis
depuis un temps depuis avant l'ol c'est
peu mais ça toujours été une restriction
maintenu par le gouvernement ce qui a
été pas qui a été ouvert ou pas ouvert
c'est elle et les restaurants ou les
pats restaurant c'est ça qui a fait la
différence la grande différence en mars
par exemple tout ce qui était culturel
et metz c'était interdit
et là ce qui concerne les situations
artistique c'est fermé cinéma t as tout
ça est refermée cependant les messes on
va permettre avec certaines conditions
ce qui à mon avis est en fonction de la
superficie de l'église on aura des
restrictions différentes cependant c'est
sûr que tous les gens sont très touchés
c'est une première phase où il y avait
beaucoup de positivisme
on sait que cette deuxième phase il ya
de l'espoir mais un manque de motivation
il ya une peur il est sûr que les ses
études de l'institut rijkaard jose qui
est une si tu prends toutes les
les les cas et surtout les virus donc
ils sont spécialisés dans sa tâche dans
ce cadre ont lancé des études en disant
qu'on est en ce moment sur un peu un
taux de 7 personnes sur 10 qui est
touchée par la maladie que ce soit par
des personnes directement pas
directement
donc ça veut dire qu'on va avoir un taux
très élevé de personnes touchées par la
pandémie
il ya une chose à retenir car pendant ce
nouveau confinement
les portugais seront quand même autorisé
à se rendre dans les bureaux de vote
pour élire leur président le premier
tour doit avoir lieu le 17 janvier puis
le 24 janvier
est-ce que vous pensez que voilà ils
vont répondre présents à cette élection
ont vu qu' il ya quand même cette
crainte d'une reprise épidémique
d'abord je fais une correction c'est que
le 24 la première la première élection
et c'est sûr que c'est très divisée ils
ont facilité les votes par anticipation
pour les pour les eee pad on va dire
pour vous puissiez comprendre de quoi on
parle et il y aura une facilité pour ces
personnes évidemment c'est très mitigé
la question de du vote qui a d'ailleurs
été soulevé par certains vers certaines
personnes qui se présentent aux
présidentielles merci beaucoup
même à gagner stobart d'avoir réagi avec
nous ce matin en direct depuis lisbonne
vous êtes un psychologue clinicienne et
psychothérapeute